the prophet Muhammad S.I wasallam told
us whoever builds a mosque for Allah
Allah will build for him a similar house
in jenah and we know the great reward
that will not only be gained but rather
will fill your grave after your death
whenever someone prays there whenever
someone gives Shah in the Masid whenever
someone learns something in the Masid
yes that will be something that you'll
have on your
scale
and welcome back welcome back to the
couch welcome back welcome back to the
place where we humiliate where we expose
where we
roast where we explicate where we
intellectually decapitate intellectually
discombobulate and dishevel our
opponents and
today the main feature will be none
other than Ben Shapiro let's take a look
at the video and come back and respond
in kind you we've been seeing these
massive marches all over the United
States in favor of Hamas if that doesn't
scare the hell out of Jews I'm not sure
exactly what will these campuses which
are supposed places of safety and and
openness and diversity well when it
comes to Jewish students feeling you
know just a little threatened by people
who are now defending mass murder of
Jews and then of of course there there's
nothing to be done are these people who
uh who are Marching in favor of Hamas
that you would want working for your
company I know I know you you are in
your dorm and you're in sconed there and
you feel so comfortable with all your
friends you tell you that you're just a
great person and all your beliefs are
exactly right tough up sweetheart bottom
line is that it's time for you to learn
that there are lots of different
opinions the discussion is good for you
it makes your reviews stronger it is
that exchange of ideas that actually
makes an intellectual Community worth
having if you're not willing to engage
in that intellectual Community you're in
the wrong place now a video like this
doesn't actually require much
elaboration because it's pretty much
self-explanatory what we're seeing with
Ben Shapiro is that he's a man who can
give it but unfortunately cannot take it
he's a man who can punch but he cannot
take a punch I don't think in physical
terms he can do I either but at least in
intellectual terms maybe he can just do
one of those things you see when it's
talking about the
leftwing the leftwing the
lefties the Liberals with a small
L he is mocking he is trying to
humiliate he is trying
to deprecate and diminish some of the
concerns and some of the common things
that are said by people but then when it
comes to this
issue where it's the Palestine Zionist
issue he effectively adopts word for
word the same Parliament attitude and
behaviors as those who he
criticizes and this is absolutely
apparent and this is actually career
ending frankly I mean this level of
hypocrisy double standard and moral
cowardice cannot see how anybody from
the right wing or the altright or from
the center right or from any part of the
political Spectrum in the Western World
can look at this and in any
way exonerate this man absolve this man
excuse this man justify for this man or
anything else this man has ended his own
career
but what I did find quite interesting
was that recently this
man actually debated one of the youths
that I debated myself Alex atheist
Alex uh in the University of Oxford I'm
sure which is very surprising but he
actually graduated so he's not an
undergrad he's re recently graduated
he's not an undergrad so this is I think
the first actual debate he's done with a
graduate in his life and unfortunately
for him he lost the debate he he didn't
even do well with him Al atheist
Alex actually done better than him and
I'm going to play One Clip which links
to the previous theme of the previous of
the previous video that we just watched
in which I think atheist Alex delivers
to uh Ben Shapiro
at least a knockout or knockdown blow
for the round let's take a look at this
particular clip he's not permitting me
per permitting my great great great
great great great great great great
grandfa to do something immoral that in
the time was not considered immoral it
wasn't considered immoral but was it
immoral by stand by standard by the
judeo Christian tradition sure by by
today's standards developed under the
judic Christian tradition immoral which
by the way you're you're living off the
you're again not to get back to argument
you're living off the remains of this I
mean where's your morality coming from
you see this is actually a very big
mistake from Ben chapiro and it actually
exposes to us something
bigger which is that
the Ben Shapiro does not have his
epistemology in order Ben shipiro doeses
not have his EP his moral epistemology
in order you see the argument that he
was effectively making was that since
culture has changed and he attributes
the change of culture to judeo-christian
values that such a a different take for
example on the punitive laws or any kind
of prescriptive injunction that may
exist within the traditional Jew Jewish
Corpus uh must be reinterpreted this is
effectively the argument now atheist
Alex does a good job in in telling him
who look who's the moral relativist now
because a moral relativist is someone
who believes that morals changed as
cultures do and there is a fine
distinction between I mean some
ethicists distinguish between the moral
relativist and the subjectivist and all
these kind of things but that's a
different question from a different day
the point to be noted is what atheist
Alex should have pushed and said is
actually why are you
attributing the change in Morality or in
ethics in the west only to Jewish or
judeo-christian values in fact we know
that there there was a Renaissance and
there was something called the
enlightenment period which which I'm
sure Shapiro is well aware of in the
enlightenment period many of the Great
philosophers of that time especially the
ethicists or those who engaged and
indulge with ethics like Emanuel Kant uh
no less actually attempted to establish
morality
without without um a reference to
religion that was the entire project
that that's why he had the hypothetical
imperative and the categorical
imperative people like him people like
John Stewart Mill yes some early
liberals and that's liberal with a small
L here did in fact invoke religious uh
teachings people like John Lock and
others but in the enlightenment period
you find you find people that
effectively strip themselves of
religious Iden some of them are atheists
and still contributed to the moral
landscape that we're finding today
people like n who the compatriot and
colleague of Ben shipiro Jordan Peterson
quotes very very often in his books who
happens to be effectively the father of
postmodernism although in somehow
Peterson and the daily y team in all of
them they criticize postmodernism but
they celebrate their founding fathers
it's a ASA Jos or an irony of pathetic
proportions however the point to be
noted is it cannot be said decisively or
definitively or in fact at all that
the enlightenment period the
enlightenment period consisted only of a
uh the judeo-christian referential point
that people were looking at Judo or
Christian values that in fact many of
the Great ethicists and philosophers
were looking at ways to establish ethics
in philosophy with it's utilitarian
philosophy of Jeremy benam and then
obviously John Stewart Mill or the
categorical imperatives of Emanuel Kant
or whatever it may be even the
postmodern school of thought without
reference to religion that's the first
point the second point is
this that if you really want to see the
scope of jurist Prudential
interpretation in the Jewish faith in
particular then what you have to do is
you have to refer number one to the
torat or the Hebrew Bible and then you
have to refer to the halakic tradition
which you can see in the for example
Palestinian talmud very conveniently
named I should say this is a Jewish book
the Palestinian talmud and the
Babylonian talmud you look at that you
look at the mid rusham which is the
exegetical framework of for example
Genesis they have something called
Genesis rabba you'll see that the
interpretive scope is unlike that which
benipur is espousing that the majority
of rabbis that were executing the Old
Testament were doing so looking at the
prescriptive the prescriptive and the
halakic meaning the Juris Prudential
versus uh more on primery value
metaphorization or spiritualization of
the text didn't reach that level that
benir is supposing that it did and in
fact many if not most especially of the
medieval sages he misrepresents my
modities previously would maintain that
position so in other words you cannot
attribute the liberalization with a
small L here liberalism to judeo
so-called judeo-christian values in fact
the uh liberalization with a small L of
the West Was despite mostly these values
having said all of this it seems to me
that these people and when I say these
people I'm talking about atheist Alex
Ben Shapiro and all all of these people
don't actually have a static objective
morality all of them are in the same
boat someone like atheist Alex would
actually agree to that maybe he would
say fine and he has in the past but I
would say people like Peterson and Ben
Shapiro are being disingenuous with you
because effectively they they adopt a
very similar similar framework a very
similar atheistic almost framework
secular framework but they just don't
have the guts to admit it to you what I
find surprising this whole thing is that
he actually put himself through that Ben
shipiro but then he debated one of the
youths that I debated some years ago in
the University of Oxford the Oxford
Forum which is atheist Alex but he can't
put himself he's to debate someone like
myself and what does that say he's
picking his opponents maybe he's trying
to build his confidence but Ben Shapiro
I think you should surrender since you
can't debate since you can't I think you
should surrender yes you should
surrender all intellectual Pursuits you
should surrender trying to defend the
Zionist project The aist Entity Israel
you should surrender in every way
because you're not built for this kind
of thing you are not built
intellectually or dispositionally for
these kinds of conflicts or
confrontations so I want to see the
White Flag I no longer want to debate
you you're not interesting for me as you
used to be I'm not going to ask ask you
for the 100th time to debate I know you
you need to build your confidence before
you face someone like myself it might
take us some
years what I want you to do I think
which is more reasonable and more
aligned with your temperament is to to
say I formally uh surrender I surrender
in all ways and uh and that I want to
see happen very
quickly hey you are you wasting your
time on social media again your brothers
and sisters in Islam net from Norway are
establishing a mid a DA Center
establishing a mid to convey The Message
of Islam is one of the best Deeds a
Muslim can do there's a huge need for it
in Norway you know this and I know this
so that makes the reward even greater so
give generously and Allah will give you
even
more